make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing on with our
discussion on the boys and as always if
you want to see the uncensored version
full of swear words and everything make
sure you guys go check out patreon
comments explain cost like a buck a
month so it's not a great big huge
expensive thing and we're gonna do
punishment max after this which believe
it or not is even more hardcore than the
boys but what this does is this picks up
with a group with a superhero group that
kind of sucks
they're called super duper and it's it's
kind of funny right because it's like in
reality
super duper is is just kind of like I
mean they mean well
right like and and it's kind of
interesting because it's like they're
the only really good superheroes have
we've seen so far which I really I guess
really sort of shines in the light that
nature of the voice comic that like when
you do encounter a team of superheroes
where all they want to do are good
things that like you can't really take
them seriously because they're kind of
goofy like one of the guys has
Tourette's and he just yells out like
and it's just it's kind of messed up
it's kind of screwed up it's heard of
him just like dropping swear words all
the time but the team does the best they
can right the big thing that goes on
here and the reason why they matter is
because what is up happening is Billy
butcher goes to meet with the legend now
as you guys know from our discussion so
far the legend is the guy who really
kind of gives him the scoop on like the
targets and you be tracked down or kind
of insider information and he's sort of
the intelligence house that allows the
boys to function in the capacity that
they do but in the events that have kind
of transpired so far billy butcher had
ultimately ended up discovering that
huey was basically kissing a star light
and the two of them were in a
relationship with each other is the
first time billy butcher learned that he
was dating one of the superheroes and so
the result is that it changes billy
butcher's entire perception of Huy
because what he starts to do is look
back on all these situations that Huey
was in and the way it looks is that
where Huey had in reality seemed to
escape by the skin of his teeth that
what it looks like is that Huey was put
into the boys by thought American to
essentially be like a be a mole to be a
spy and that all the scenarios that
unfolded where he basically should have
died because he was unprepared for the
various fights or what-have-you that
essentially the heroes are going light
on him because their secret mission was
don't kill Huey and so basically it
looks like Huey is a Vaught American spy
and that's what he pitches to the legend
and the legend immediately calls and
says no there's no way that's possibly
true right like this seems like a lot of
nonsense one of the things he says here
is have you ever considered the
possibility that Huey doesn't know who
Starlite is he doesn't know this she's
part of the seven that he just sees her
as a girl now the story as has been
depicted so far lends itself to that
right like there were two people who
just randomly met in a park and struck
up a conversation and started going from
there
but the stance of billy butcher is
because of the nature of the boys and
what they do it would be an insanely
high coincidence if Huey who's a part of
a part of a group that tracks down
superheroes and either kills them or
forces them to divulge information or
uses them for their own cause but
somehow be unaware of whose star light
is as a member of the seven but remember
starlight wears a mask for the most part
she doesn't really go out there with
their face being seen by the entire
world and so because that is kind of
intriguing right it's kind of
interesting because it looks like in
reality it seems like a massive
coincidence but there's also the
possibility that Huey really is a mole
for Vaught American that's spine on the
boys it's cool like it's a really
interesting concept
it's sort of just thrown in there the
other half of this is that the team's
super duper is kind of a team it's just
sort of there for the stickers think of
the nostalgic why they're kind of like
this science fiction team like from the
future you know that kind of a thing
they're almost like the Legion of
super-heroes to a degree from DC Comics
but the way that this plays out is that
their leader is essentially gone right
he's been taken out and he's basically
being replaced by a pretty hardcore guy
and I don't mean hardcore insofar as
he's like hyper violent well I mean I
guess he kind of is but hardcore and the
so he doesn't really care about anything
right so we'll cover that more once we
get into it but this guy's name is of
course mal chemical and so in response
to the fact that Billy butcher believes
Huy might be as Pfeiffer bought American
what he ends up doing is actually siming
Huy to basically go and spy on super
dooper and to in turn install these
various little you know monitoring and
spying devices and so on and so forth
and that's kind of the issue is this
like SuperDuper is a team that can't
really be taken seriously so why is Huy
being spying on Beast at the spy um in
the first place and that's what Huey
asks right like this mission is stupid
this team is ridiculous they can't
really be taken seriously they don't do
anything nefarious they never have so
there's no reason for us to spy on them
right but in term Billy but just like
this is your assignment go and carry it
out and it's one of these things where
while the boys usually disagree where
they can disagree with what what it is a
Billy Bush it wants them to do at the
end of the day he's a leader of the team
and so they essentially carry out these
various missions here and so it's kind
of intriguing because of course what
this does is it leads to really kind of
returning to you up to the super duper
team and they're just kind of characters
who are a little bit goofy right like
one of the characters for example she
has the ability
Fage through things but like her powers
don't really work that well well if they
kind of work occasionally and so she
goes to face through a wall and walks
into it and that's why she's got like a
black eye and a broken nose is because
her powers don't really work
consistently they just kind of go on and
do their thing and that's that's why
it's messed up because then you
basically jump into the introduction of
mal chemical and the guy immediately
starts treating him like right like
that's that's the first thing that
happens he starts treating him like crap
like he's making fun of the guy who has
Tourette's and just like yells out swear
words basically this kind of poking fun
at him laughing at his disability
different things like that the guy's
basically a total jerk and when you have
like aunt says who's there is kind of
like the leader of the team really more
of like a mother for the team kind of
encouraging them and saying hey like you
guys can do this if you guys are capable
of all that kind of stuff and in a lot
of ways is really sort of the emotional
lynchpin for the team like now chemical
doesn't really take her seriously he's
like you know you're adorable you know
but like this team is basically a bunch
of goofballs like I don't even know why
you really waste your time on them like
they're all really just kind of
ridiculous and so what you end up having
is the team that goes on patrol now
immediately this is kind of silly right
like when they go on Patrol it is kind
of laughable because I mean they're
doing good things but like their patrol
is like they're going around their
neighborhood and there's literally a cat
stuck in a tree and so one of them who
has the ability to shape-shift basically
like taps into the tree and then in turn
just like scares the cat off and the
idea is for one of them to essentially
lay down on the ground there's great big
huge you know overweight kid lay down on
the ground and the cattle like jump down
and it'll land on him as a safe landing
and then the cat will be okay
the team is silly is really what it is
like it's it's sort of this kind of
goofball team but at the same time you
can't help but feel bad for them right
because like they're trying their best
but the big thing or leave at least one
of the big things that comes out of this
is is really like Mother's Milk now this
is important because what this shows is
that just because Billy butcher is
leading the team does not mean they
follow Billy butcher with like some sort
of religious fervor right like Mother's
Milk shuts down it says okay so like
he's talking to Frenchie he's like
here's the problem here super duper is a
team that can't really be taken
seriously and the whole pitch by Billy
butcher is mal chemicals being moved to
become a leader of the team so maybe
like super uber is gonna be moved up in
the range so they're gonna become like a
more serious contender and that's why he
sent Hughie to spy on them and to make
sure you know to see if that was gonna
be the case but the reality is there
were a team that's incapable of really
doing anything meaningful so there's no
way fought American would invest
I more money to move them into a like a
more serious position because they're
not meant to be taken seriously they're
there just for the sake of sales and
that's it they just play their role they
do their part and they'll never be
anything more than that in fridge she's
like yeah that kind of makes sense it's
always like if that's the case why would
he send Hughie to spy on that team like
there's something else going on here
like Billy butcher's doing something
else none of this really seems to make
any sense and so that's the issue is
because at the end of the day like it's
one of these things where Billy butcher
seems to have his own scheme and
Mother's Milk she's trying to figure out
what's going on because the reality is
that mal chemical is a character that's
not to be trifled with
right like he's crazy he's he's just a
horrible guy and exceedingly dangerous
and if Huey was sent on what what
amounts to a suicide run that ultimately
it could get him killed and so
essentially the way that Mother's Milk
sees this Billy butcher's got his own
agenda who even knows what it is and
he's literally sent Huey into the Lions
Den and Huey could die and that business
sit right with Mother's Milk is one of
these cool things are basically the
members of the boys look out for each
other especially when they're being sent
on a mission that's questionable by
Billy butcher and so what you end up
getting is kind of transitioning back to
Malcom achill and a superduper now
chemical really just kind of starts
teasing on sis and making fun of her and
saying look like why do you really even
care about these guys like I get that
what you're trying to do is a good thing
and that's adorable
but a reality like this team ish and
like you're dumb for leading it like
this team's not really a serious thing
the other half of this is that on sis
really looks at it and says like you're
being sent here as a punishment for us
right because like I guess for whatever
reason we're not making enough money or
we're not doing something that that
thought American deems to be worthwhile
and so you're basically Vincent being
sitting here as a punishment for us and
so it's one of these things were kind of
like you stay away right like if you're
gonna be the leader of the team that's
fine Vladimir can put you here there's
nothing we can do to stop it but like
leave us alone and quit being it and
just let us do our thing because you're
not doing anything but like tearing down
these guys who are just trying to do the
right thing and it's a good point to
make right because that's really all mal
chemicals doing like you have these guys
I sure they've got their downsides and
they are for the most part a team of
people who are essentially inept but it
doesn't take away from the fact they're
trying to do great things and why tear
that down it's a really good point to
make the issue with this is that like
where you end up having one of the guys
who's just kind of sitting there really
the character of body you know the the
overweight kid who's just sitting there
and just like shoveling ice cream
minutes now if black holes like well I
can this I can consume all kinds of
matter so he basically takes in like a
spoon and a bowl in the whole nine yards
and starts choking on the spoon and this
is where things
interesting because Huey watches this
unfold and he could have easily taken
the stance of saying like walk one my
superhero in the world of this guy
chokes to death whatever but remember he
was a good guy and there's a lot more
humanity a Huey did we see it like
really and like Billy butcher himself
and so Huey of course knowing how CPR
works knowing that was part of his
training course with regards to the boy
so that if any of them ever struggled or
they need to be resuscitated he'd be the
one to be able to help them out he jumps
in basically cuts the throat of black
hole so he can breathe and then in turn
basically says somebody called an
ambulance you know incident essentially
saves the life of the sky all of which
is being witnessed by Billy butcher and
all of which Billy butcher is construing
in his own mind as evidence of the fact
that Huey is basically working for
Vaught American and that's where things
get kind of crazy is because from there
you basically end up dealing with Bobby
who's sort of just doing his thing and
being goofy and jumping down the road
and lands in the car of Huey absolutely
smashes the car and then everything
begins to pop off because what is up
happening is of course they bring Huey
in in order to get some get Huey some
medical attention you know here we
basically being a friend of SuperDuper
at this point and then it's her like now
chemical comes in he's like who in the
heck is this guy you know he restarts
planting you know various spy devices
around there different things like that
but the result is that he's kind of
welcomed into the team now chemicals
just kind of in and out right he's a guy
who doesn't really take the team
seriously doesn't really care he's just
kind of doing his own thing
Huey's officially like welcomed into the
team like hey you know like we're glad
to have you on board and you know you're
a friend of the team and and that kind
of a thing and that's when stuff gets
kind of nuts because what you have is
you have Bobby who sits down with on sis
and then like the two of them start
talking about like their own secrets and
different things like that way you know
there are really dark moments and and so
on and of course Huey's kind of
continuing to to spy on the team and on
sis basically reveals that she's got a
fear of giant Underpants
and the reason why is because when she
was a little kid when she was an any
bitty baby she was staying with her aunt
and basically like on a windy day her
aunts Underpants blew off the
clothesline landed on her and basically
like scare the crap out of her well what
you end up finding out here is this is
not Bobby this is Malcolm achill
masquerading his body who basically has
the the secrets of this chick and so
what is up going down here is that when
this when this whole thing is sort of
transpires that basically like aunt
Cisco's walking into a room looking for
Malcolm achill and he's like a giant
pair of underwear and like descends on
this chick and just starts tormenting
her like it's miss giant underwear you
know just like tormenting the hell out
of this woman everybody comes running
everybody comes screaming he in turn
starts
Banting the rest of the team and then he
basically lays it on the line and says
here's the deal like here's what's gonna
happen from this point going forward
like I'm doing my thing like I'm doing
my thing from this point on you guys are
gonna do whatever I tell you to none of
you really call Vaught American none of
you gonna tell anybody what's going on
if you don't I'll just kill you guys and
we'll sweep it under the rug and call it
a day we'll say you guys died in some
accident and nobody's gonna care you
guys don't really make enough money from
on America anyway so let us replace you
with somebody else or whatever the case
is but lays down the hammer and
immediately just like continues a path
of tormenting them now while all this
goes on this is a very important thing
here while all this goes on Mother's
Milk has been investigating the whole
situation with like Huey and so on and
so forth and what he does is basically
track down the main contact for the
seven with Vlad American and immediately
corners him and is like what's going on
with Huey like why did you put him in
our group as like you know some kind of
spy and the response about American from
what he says he's not a spy right he
doesn't work for them he's like I don't
care what you guys need him he's not
he's not our man and so in response to
that Mother's Milk basically has a
confirmation he meets and then calls up
Billy butcher and is like what have you
done like you said this guy on a suicide
mission to monitor some stupid team with
one of the most dangerous characters one
of those dangerous superheroes is out
there because you believe that he's a
spy for Vaughn American you sent this
guy on the you know into the Lions Den
on a suicide mission because you're
being stupid because you're being
paranoid
and you're getting carried away with
your own nonsense and that's when when
Billy would you basically says yeah but
like I saw the guy making out with
starlight you know and that's when
mothers know what kind of gets the other
half of the equation and that's what was
going on here is both sides were
basically operating with only half the
information mother's milk only have ever
had half the story and dill a butcher
only ever had half the story but neither
one really seemed to go into and
investigate what was going on with the
whole scenario they just ran with what
they had and called it a day from there
like Malcolm achill sort of goes nuts
and says here's what's gonna happen like
things start getting insane now of
course
Huey pops up here and basically says
like this is not gonna happen but
basically like Huey jumps in and says
this is not gonna happen the problem
with this is now chemicals way above his
league right like now chemical starts
like shifting into a gaseous form and
then turns his arms are like these super
sharp super sort of tentacles and just
starts like cutting Huey to shreds
things are popping off fast but this is
the ingenuity of Billy butcher and this
really shows the inexperience of Huey
here because Billy butcher looks at this
and says okay
it sounds like Mother's Milk is right
right like Huey is not an agent working
for von America
and so instead he basically walks in
there and says fine like if now
chemicals gonna set himself into a
gaseous form he'll just set it on fire
so he literally just lights a lights the
lighter to the guy and lights his top
which is hilarious because he just turns
into this giant ball of fire just like
burns to death and it's kind of nuts but
it from there like he grabs Huey and
they basically end up departing now of
course it's not initially without the in
initial skirmish of sorts between Billy
butcher in and super duper because of
course one of them starts popping off
with his with his his Tourette syndrome
and Billy initially takes it as an
offense of course now of course Huey
ends up being the one to save it and
says what they can't help it it's the
guys thing you know he's got Tourette
syndrome there's nothing you could
really do about that but once you get
back to their base of operations
everything pops off between Billy
butcher and mother's milk and that's the
cool thing is because mother's milk is
not a guy who just follows why he's not
just like a follower here right the guy
does what he needs to do like he goes
through and says look like here's how
things really are I'm not just gonna
idly sit by and let like Billy butcher
send one of us on a suicide mission
that's ridiculous like it's it's silly
to believe that that's gonna be the case
and so as a result of that what you
basically in the beauty here is
ultimately Billy butcher backing down in
something okay look it was my mistake
right like I screwed up I didn't trust
our guys and that's kind of the big
issue here is that ultimately Billy
butcher doesn't really trust Huey and in
reality I would say he doesn't trust
anybody he doesn't trust any of those
guys and that's kind of a big deal right
for him to just kind of work alongside
these guys and not really trust any of
him especially in the else's he's known
them that long and so ultimately like
what he tells mother's milk is okay look
here we can't know about this right here
we can't know then I basically set him
on a suicide mission
because I thought he was a spy for
bought America because if he we learned
that he would bail on the team and if he
did who knows what information he could
basically reveal about American if he so
chose but the reality of this and really
Billy but sure isn't entirely wrong Huey
is kind of a liability right let you
somewhat of a liability for the team and
so far as you know with him being in a
relationship with with starlight she
could sway him to the side but it could
be that he's just revealing facts not
really paying attention to what he's
saying
you know things could slip out there's a
lot of stuff that could come from him
associating with the superhero community
in a romantic way they could ultimately
sabotage everything the boys are doing
and so that's kind of the crazy thing is
because would that being the case of
course Mother's know basically leaves
and then it switches over to homeland
and this is when homeland er really
begins to snap here right because kind
of a back thing going on sort of
I guess a side plot taking place in this
is that over the course of time that
what we've seen with home Lander is he's
become more and more extreme where
homeland er was really somewhat of a
company man right like kind of falling
rank-and-file with what bought American
wanted him to do as time has passed he's
really began to kind of get carried away
with his own power and really kind of
come to the realization the Von American
can't really stop him right the bought
American can't really do anything to
keep him from going on a warpath and
that's what he kinda America kind of
realizes here he sits down and he says
you know what I can do I can do pretty
much anything and it's about time that I
get started and that's what you're gonna
start seeing going forward is home
Lander systematically losing his mud
going more and more crazy and doing all
kinds of insane things and ultimately
getting to the point where he just sort
of loses his mind and becomes really the
answer to the question what would happen
if Superman just became this insane
villain but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you guys are new here to come this
explain it make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob Ford if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and as always if you
want to see the uncensored version of
this all the swear words and
inappropriate imagery and all that kind
of stuff make sure you guys go check out
patreon.com/crashcourse N'Diaye we have
a lot of Austin's and our patreon as
well as G Knossos 916 des gnosis didn't
give us a first and last name so we
kinda had to roll with it I didn't
mention your last names and I think you
guys didn't want me to throw them out
there but I want to say thank you to you
all by the way your Rob four rings
should be on their way for our honor
guard members of the Rob core for these
special patrons your custom Rob four
rings should be on their way they're
being shipped to me after that I will
have them shipped to you stay tuned
keep your eye on patreon and your
messages and you will hear about them
coming to you thank you
[Music]